crap
[Music]
hello my name is Sylvie Kakashi and I am
a marriage and family therapist and I've
been coaching couples and singles for
over seven years and working as a
therapist for the last three years the
past few months have been kind of a
rocky road for us so what exactly are
the five love languages so the five love
languages were created by dr. Gary
Chapman he started noticing patterns of
things that would be complained from
each partner in a relationship there's
five fundamental expressions of love and
so those are the way that we actually
receive it words of affirmation is a way
of expressing love to your romantic
partner it can be anything from verbal
compliment encouraging words and also
being very humble in our words not
making demands from our partner but
gentle requests how do people develop
love languages and there's actually two
different ways we develop them so as a
child have a certain way that our
parents give love to us if you were a
child that spent a lot of quality time
with your parents and they were really
focused and present with you then it
would be natural that to be your
fundamental love language but sometimes
what happens is the opposite of that my
mom was very worthy she would praise me
Allah say like oh wow you did such a
great job so proud of you I just got
ready for work and I wrote her a couple
of post-it notes and I'm just gonna play
some around the house and I also wrote
her a car she left me all these little
cute notes around the house so there's a
little good morning one
this is the first time she's done that
I'm really excited alright so getting
into my car I noticed something else
okay so she got me a card it says our
life is perfectly amazed these words
mean a lot to me especially before I'm
going to work the second one is quality
time spending focused attention with
your partner physical touch doesn't have
to be necessarily sexual but just having
close proximity my love language is acts
of service acts of service is something
that takes time effort energy and
planning so if I know my partner loves
me to do the chores at home that's an
act of service that I can give my
partner maybe I also got it from my
parents cuz they would always make me do
chores around the house like Pat me on
the back for doing them after we took
the test and I found out that she was
acts of service it kind of made a little
more sense as to why she would get angry
at me oh that's nothing it's always her
doing the laundry picking up after me
what I recommend the couples I work with
to do is rather than waiting for an
explosion moment like a fight because
what I usually happens when we don't
feel fulfilled in our love language I
have them do a weekly exercise asking
them you know if you could choose five
acts of service that you would love for
me to do so the two things that I chose
to do is one I want to cook for her I
know she's been like kind of Craven
pokey I really did like all our laundry
for once it's empty
whoo Keisha thank you
and the last is gifts so when a lot of
ancient traditions gifts have been very
popular way of a visual and symbolic way
of showing love to someone I would
probably say it'd be a tie up between
gifts and touch I'm an only child and an
only grandchild growing up I got a lot
of gifts from my mom my nanny and my
poppies it's awesome that you can see
right away that that was probably
present in your childhood always staying
curious with each other what way of
giving the gifts have I done that you
were really touched by so today is our
weekly Sunday Funday
and I'm about to go pick up Christina I
got a little gift I'm gonna try and
surprise her with it should be fun you
did it
why are you - that is so cool would you
think of the gifts on the Sunday Funday
it was pretty amazing I'm not gonna lie
I am a sucker for jewelry and he knows
it thank you
I know jewelry is a pretty safe bet and
I like to get them kind of personalized
whether it's getting something written
on them engraved today I bought trying a
gift he has no idea what it is it's
sitting on his bed let's see how it goes
what were you like my running shoes so
why'd you think I loved it finally got
my dinosaur pinata and wanting that
forever and I've needed new running
shoes for six months so let's not fall
over Thank You Ben
especially with the little notes and the
card that she got me words on affection
I like that stuff how did you feel felt
like that she actually did the laundry
for once right off the bat you guys may
be thinking were very materialistic
because we love receiving gifts much
significant others which isn't
necessarily not true but it's not
completely true we like our gifts
because it's going the extra mile and in
our case it's how we really communicate
our love for each other and get your
partner something it can be cheap
expensive doesn't really matter as long
as they know you got it from having
Silvie examined our love language really
helped us out
[Music]